we didn't get right by to the tension
bob mcdonnell's came down one empty feet
and the next teammates he make the next
two right there
trailblazer in this form
[Music]
back and forth they go in this game
there will be on top again long pass
Lucca of those Canadians up all from
Toronto Sion off little off the timing
racking up the points
[Music]
the first NDP call
[Music]
I like the way he plays makes a good for
bathroom like RJ pair play a little
defense you got a couple of steals here
get lit with a box shellfish two extra
pass
yeah we're gonna definitely get some
battles in the show tomorrow Sunday's
good guys have a great year Brandon
Clark
[Music]
just like hey you day
bulb to rim the man many he came to see
on top from Syosset Thunder I think you
should bury uh I think guys are
expecting thunder the kind of bow take a
step back this year but Chris Paul to
leave them I think there
can compete at a high level right okay
Jackson's been a good three-point
shooter this year with that push shot
parents with the jab and that'll take us
to our first time out faster you try to
definitely good we're adding pass the
language Akbar I remember well back to
what I said about to listen to this man
east of the Rising Stars game or
competitors we got a former champion
it's right next to me along with Myles
Turner a Brian Anderson Jared Greenberg
our reporter I'll have a great teammate
at Victor Oladipo he's been out for a in
[Applause]
generation Jackson we see it RJ berry
dunk right here look at the rest look at
the pace man let's write I want to see
he almost got that joy
Simeon legacy that carries on in
Kendrick
Williamson from his AAU team a jobber
and look at this bad let's see here
cats way out there this is the fools are
writing down to the Windy City right now
via Nate bjorkgren and Hatcher in the
top oh oh wow
yes up so quick okay let's see let's see
where we're sitting
good push Road
[Applause]
Senate race they looked at the what's
more he goes to Zion Johnson he picks up
the guys I on Duncan is he's picking
poison on that what it's hand him right
there tilted now that was excited by the
second half
this scion a decoy or that maybe I'll
start we come out here just beat
everybody around the league and the two
headliners Ernest gracious I'm making
some highlight just snuck it over the
rim we played against em you gotta get
out that's this forty percent shooter
from behind the arc I'm sure I like what
they're doing down there - yeah
sharpshooter the high-low kind of the
you can shout the Dallas Texas 18 points
a game a 13 point increase
Sparty the Hornets are getting hot
ladies and gentlemen
that we look right Adam - that's what we
call a business decision thought leader
right there the jumps what's the run
here miles just has three threes in this
quarter he's left-handed
doing that what is right polish back
there explosive shock scores the world
by 20 in that third quarter that world
team missed their last ten of their last
13 shots was really two boroughs
he plays the three-pointer suit three
years at the University of Illinois and
then he transferred to watch them look
back right here transfers Dhokla had a
redshirt year and goes smooth 360 action
this is too easy 60 finish don't try it
at home ladies
[Applause]
it's TAC that's a big shot right there
Sexton Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
very unassuming clear what do you think
it means to these guys four of their
countrymen on the floor
thanks Columbia with the fetish clan let
gives a two-point game
that's I said they'll they earned a lot
of respect you know I think that
stretches incredible Jared Greenberg
[Music]
first ever Japanese player to be drafted
he had a great run at Gonzaga he's got
the big Japanese following tonight
that's one guy that gets the dunk so
this is the time where everybody wants
to sit wise I'm and judge throw it up
there
[Applause]
back-to-back he in with a hat see who
wouldn't have to see
[Applause]
- John give the job